human dernier long métrage de yann
arthus bertrand
trois ans de travail 90 tournage pour
aboutir aux témoignages d'hommes et de
femmes sur le bonheur l'amour la guerre
le travail ou encore la famille ou le
racisme
le livre you man sorti en septembre
s'inscrit quant à lui dans le
prolongement du film
l'auteur dédicace son ouvrage aux pavés
du canal de montigny le bretonneux
samedi dernier bah je trouve que c'est
déjà magnifique de faire passer des
idées par aussi des photos des
témoignages tout ce qu'il fait tout son
travail à la fois ton dans les livres
que dans les films on le livre c'est de
décrypter un petit peu le film le film
commence par exemple par par un type est
en prison qui a tué une femme et son
fils et qui est dont la grand-mère des
gens qui ont été signés lui pardonne il
se met à pleurer donc on a été voir la
grand-mère est donc dans le lait via
l'explication des deux pourquoi cette
grand-mère est capable de pardonner à la
personne qui a tué sa fille et son
petit-fils divisé en six thèmes
on y retrouve des témoignages forts
extrait du film développé et étayé par
des articles de grands journaux des
infographies ainsi que des informations
filmographique l'ensemble est illustré
par de grandes photos aériennes et par
des making of des équipes de tournage
le livre c'est une continuation sur
human s'est passé un film c'est aussi un
projet pourquoi ce qu'on n'arrive pas à
vivre ensemble
voilà qu'elles sont
voilà pourquoi l'homophobie pourquoi les
réfugiés pourquoi le la cette pauvreté
donc c'est une question qu'on peut se
poser et bien sûr rentre pas tout dans
un film et je pense qu'il y aura
beaucoup d'autres personnes que moi qui
grilleront qui filmeront derrière ça
c'est un problème là passionné par les
questions humaines
yann arthus-bertrand planche sur son
prochain projet intitulé who won un long
métrage sur le rôle et la place des
femmes dans le monde